listen to that wner hog talking about
the jungle it's really hilarious have
you heard it no I have not but wner
Herzog as a
way you should play you should play it
for the you know as an interlude in the
yeah it's on YouTube it's it's
awesome I love him so much uh he's great
was he the director of happy people life
in the tiger I think also he did that
bear documentary The Bear documentary
this thing about penguins yeah
the depr the analysis psycho analysis of
P psych yeah the penguins like headed
for like mountains like that are like 70
miles away and penguin has just head for
Doom basically well he was had a cynical
take I I have a he could be just a brave
Explorer and there'll be great stories
told about him amongst the penguin
population for many centuries to
come
that